and openly gay and I am Muslim
gay Muslims are very much present and in
solidarity with their other LGBT
brothers and sisters we stand at both
these intersections we felt that there
is an attack on both of our identities
we're doubly impacted we're tired of the
anti-muslim rhetoric and at the same
time violence is a part of what the
majority of LGBT people in the world
continue to live with
Don Trump has made it fashionable for
this to be a summer of intolerance and
homophobia Islamophobia has been
existent in our community for a long
long time the only thing that tram did
is actually put face to it they ate the
gays as much as they hate so now they
have to pick and choose what are they
going to do who are they going to hate
more we forgotten about the trans people
who have died we've forgotten about the
Latino people have died we have not been
saying their names and all of this is
because of the focus on you know Muslim
terror radicalism people who've never
cared about our well-being and who've
actually fought against our dignity and
our equality are now co-opting our
bodies and our struggles and our skins
to fuel and feed their own agenda
you